Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Kimas und hier, ich bin hier erstens. Ich werde das Aufnahmengespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Bitte geben Sie mir Bescheid, wenn etwas unklar ist. Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Heinrich Bauer.
Heinrich Bauer?
Könnten Sie bitte vornamen und Nachnamen langsam bestabieren?
Ich bestabiere meinen Vornamen.
Hallo, Ewi, Emil, Ewi, Ida, Nv, Nordpol, Nv, Nordpol, Rw, Richard, Iw, Ida, Cw, Cs, und Hw, Hallo.
Alles klar.
Bw, Bertha, Ag, Anton, Uw, Ulla, Ewi, Emil, Rw, Richard.
Bauch her.
Bauch ohne Haare.
Alles klar.
Herr Bauer, wie heiß sind Sie und wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin am 18. Januar 1956 geboren.
65.
56.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter 85 groß und ich wiege aktuell ungefähr 80 Kilogramm.
80 Kilogramm?
Welche Bescheid haben Sie im Moment?
Ich komme heute wegen Ihnen, weil ich seit ungefähr 2 Wochen gelb bin.
Gelb bin?
Ich bin gelb und ich habe Haut kratzt.
Ich mische mich juckt es überall.
An den Beinen, an den Armen, am Bauch.
An der Brust, überall juckt es mich.
Ich muss mich kratzen.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrochen?
Ich habe Übelkeit, Erbrochen habe ich nicht.
Nein.
Haben Sie die Beschwerden plus sich oder langsam begonnen?
Also das ist jetzt seit 2 Wochen ungefähr und das geht nicht weg.
Ich denke jetzt ist langsam gekommen, aber mir ist das jetzt seit 2 Wochen aufgefallen
und meine Frau hat mich aufmerksam gemacht.
Anis, klar.
Haben Sie Schmerzen?
Nein.
Leiden Sie unter Wasserlastenprobleme oder Sturggangprobleme?
Ich kann gut Wasserlasten, ich kann auch gut auf Toilette gehen.
Wie Sie ihr Urin auf?
Mein Urin ist dunkel.
Dunkel?
Er ist erst aus Dunkel geworden.
Dunkel geworden.
Haben Sie Schwellungen in Körper?
Ich habe keine Schwellungen.
Herr Bauer, haben Sie weitere Beschwerden?
Es kratzen, es juckt mich überall.
Ich muss mich die ganze Zeit kratzen.
Ich habe auch weniger Appetit als sonst.
Weniger?
Appetit.
Haben Sie in nächstes Zeit Ab- oder Su genommen?
Ich habe abgenommen, ich habe dort wenig Appetit und deswegen habe ich ungefähr 5 kg in den letzten 2 Wochen abgenommen.
2 Wochen?
Haben Sie weitere Beschwerden oder?
Was zum Beispiel?
Leiden Sie unter Atemprobleme oder Herzprobleme?
Herzprobleme.
Herzprobleme zum Beispiel.
Herz.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Allgemein-Geräuschheit vorstellen.
Haben Sie viel Bauschüttelfroß oder Nachschweiß?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Schlafen Sie gut, Herr Bauer?
Ich schlafe gut und viel.
Was meinen Sie, viel Schlafe?
Ich bin müde als sonst.
Sehr müde.
Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, Herr Bauer?
Ich habe Bluthochdruck und ich habe auch ähre die Kolesterolinwerte.
Hyper-Kolesterolinwerte?
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck und Hyper-Kolesterolinwerte?
Schon seit über 30 Jahren.
Beide 30 Jahre?
Ja, zuerst kam der Blutdruck, das Kolesterolin, habe ich jetzt vielleicht 25 Jahre oder so.
25?
Gepäst noch ein paar Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, das sind die einzig nicht.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ich wurde an den Knien, beide Knien sind operiert worden.
Welche Operationen?
Den Meniskus rechts und links habe ich ein neues Kniegelenk.
Bei Arthrose.
Sind Sie vorstandig geil?
Ja, mein Hausarzt hat beim letzten Checkup gesagt, es wäre alles in Ordnung gewesen.
Waren Sie in nächster Zeit im Ausland?
Ich war im Weihnachten, war ich in Thailand.
Thailand?
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, gegen Blutdruck und gegen Kolesterolin.
Was nehmen Sie und wie häufig?
Ich nehme Ramipri morgens und abends ein.
Ich nehme auch nur die Pin morgens und abends ein.
Ich nehme HCT morgens einmal ein.
Ich nehme auch nur die Pin morgens und abends einmal ein.
Wie viele Medikamente haben Sie?
Ich glaube, es sind 5 Milligramm bei Ramipri und bei Ludipine.
Und die HCT, ich glaube, sind 45 Milligramm.
Und die HCT?
HCT ist, glaube ich, 25 Milligramm.
Nehmen Sie bei Bedarf Medikamente ein, Herr Bauch?
Selten, aber wenn ich Schmerzen habe, nehme ich gerne Ibuprofen ein.
Welche Dosierung?
Ich glaube, das sind die 400er.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergenie oder Unfartrichlichkeiten?
Ich bin Raktosentolerant.
Wie äußert diese Unfartrichlichkeit?
Mit Blühungen, Bauchschmerzen, Durchfutter.
Herr Bauch, rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Haben Sie früher Gerahre?
Nein, noch nie.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Gar nicht.
Haben Sie Drogen probiert?
In meiner Jugend, ja.
Probieren Sie einmal?
Ich nehme keine Drogen ein.
Aber Sie sagen, im Jugend probiert?
Ich habe in meiner Jugend vor 30, 40 Jahren, aber ich probiert, ja.
Welche Drogen?
Möchte ich nicht sagen.
Alles klar.
Ich gebe es in ihrer Familie bestimmt, er krankungen.
Wen meinen Sie mit Familie?
Zum Beispiel, mit der Familie, die sind schon lange gestorben.
Tut mir leid, aber ich bin ja auch schon 70 Jahre alt.
Hab ich in ihrer Familie nicht gestorben.
Ich habe in meinem Jugend, die ich gestorben habe,
die haben sich schon lange gestorben.
Haben Sie in Ihrer Familie zum Beispiel krankungen?
Oder Krebs?
Krebs ist nicht bekannt, aber Bluturtuk hat auch meinen Vater gehabt.
Mein Bruder hat das gehabt, meine Schwester hat das.
Alles klar.
Glauben Sie, dass ich Krebs habe?
Nein, aber diese Routine-Frage.
Ach so, okay.
Warum sind Ihre Eltern gestorben?
Mein Vater ist im Krieg verstorben.
Sie sind erst im Krieg verstorben.
Und meine Mutter ist sehr früh gestorben.
Man glaubt, dass sein Herzinfarkt war.
Alles klar.
Viel, viel haben Sie, ein Bruder und ein Schwester.
Genau, ich habe sie gestorben.
Ich habe sie gestorben.
Ich habe ein Bruder und ein Schwester gehabt.
Mein Bruder ist aber auch schon verstorben.
Warum ist er gestorben?
Der ist leider in einem Autounfall verstorben.
Meine Frau.
Wie ist Ihr Familienzustand?
Ich gebe meine Frau zusammen.
Ich stehe mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Haben sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder insgesamt.
Sind ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, bis auf meinen Sohn, der hat auch Blutung.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Render.
Wo arbeiten Sie früher?
Ich möchte ein paar Algemeinsüchter stellen.
Ich habe sie nicht verstanden.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu ihrer Algemeinsüchter stellen.
Sie waren in der Hausarzt?
Ja, ich war nicht in der Hausarzt.
Haben Sie andere Bechverdn beim Wasalassun oder Nebis?
Bis auf die dunkel Verfärbung habe ich keine Bechverdn.
Alles klar.
Das war meine Frage.
Herr Bauer, möchte Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, denken Sie, dass ich etwas Schlimmes haben könnte?
Nein, ich kann noch nicht genau sagen.
Ich werde die Körperlärmung durchführen und Blut abnehmen.
Sobald die Ergebnisse da sind, informiere ich Sie darüber.
Was glauben Sie denn? Ist das etwas Stimmers?
Ich vermute das.
Sie ein Almondesnut.
Okay.
Dann warte ich jetzt hier.
Danke schön.
Eine gute Seminierung gemacht.
Haben Sie eine andere Frage?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie in Ihrer Familie 5 Verdn?
Nein.
Danke.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Wenn Sie in Thailand waren, haben Sie ein Hotel oder ein Hotel?
Ja, und dann haben Sie ein Hotel.
Danke schön.
Dann war meine Frage.
Haben Sie Ihre Stuhlveränderung gemacht?
Ja, mein Stuhl ist auch entfernt.
Es ist beischartig, lehmverfärberungs- oder graue gelbe Konsistenz.
Noch Fragen, Kollegen?
Wenn Sie nicht Fragen haben, könnten wir Arsatz-Gebremfang?
Ja.
Ihr habt eine kurze Frage.
Vielleicht ist das etwas abseits von dem Thema, aber in neugieriger Frage,
in welcher Krieg ist Ihr Vater gestorben?
Im zweiten Weltkrieg.
Oh, danke schön.
Warum haben wir das gefangen?
Neugierig nur.
Danke.
Gibt es aus Ihrer Sicht eine wichtige Frage, die nicht gesteilt wurde?
Gibt es eine Schmerzen?
Vielleicht im rechten Oberbau auch noch mal Fragen,
ob es Schmerzen gibt oder nicht.
Schmerzen gibt keine Schmerzen.
Erst kommt der als schmerzfrei.
Aber man hätte noch fragen können,
ob Sie auf die rechte Seite drücken, ob Schmerzen oder nicht Schmerzen.
Das kann man fragen.
Ich habe ein bisschen Schmerzen und eine Verschwellung oder Tumor gefragt.
Haben Sie gefragt?
Ansonsten muss alles gut gewesen, denke ich.
Ja, ich denke auch, Herr Kultus.
Könnten wir erst als gechefere Anfang?
Natürlich.
Bitte schön, Kollege.
Guten Tag.
Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte heute neue Patient vorstellen.
Herr Bauer ist 70-jährige Patient,
der sich wegen 2 Wochen aufgetreten hat,
die Priorität bei uns vorstellt.
Die Frage, ob Schmerzen
nicht wirklich ein Problem ist,
ist die Bewegung der Anamnesen.
Sie ist sehr fett und in der Petenz.
Seit 2 Wochen haben sie 5 kg Gewicht verloren.
Anfordererkrankungen leidet die Patient an,
seit 30 Jahren, artellische Partonie, seit 25 Jahren an Hyperkulesternämie.
Herr Bauer hat wegen beidem keine operiert.
Der Patient ist vollständig geimpft und er hat am Weihnachten in Thailand erwar.
Er nimmt Ramipril 5 mg morgens und abends, Amlötebin 5 mg morgens und abends,
und Atoröstatin 40 mg abends.
Er hat 400 mg Beibedarf, er hat Laktose in Toleranz, die sich durch Meteorismus und Diarröte äußert.
Herr Bauer ist ein Nehrauer und Alkoholtrinke.
Er hat im Jugend 2-3 Mal Drogen probiert.
Die Mutter und der Vater sind verstorben.
Herr Bauer hat ein Bruder und eine Schwester.
Beide Geschwister hatten artellische Partonie.
Herr Bauer ist verheiratet und hat 3 Gesunde Kinder.
Der Patient ist eine Rente, aber früher hat er als Architekt tätig.
Er hat keine Schmerzen.
Ich würde mit Körperlöhre und Abdomenokrophie diese Diagnose auslisten.
Welche Diagnose kommt bei diesem Patient noch in Frage?
Ich erinnere nur Hepatitis.
Wenn er jetzt nicht im Ausland gewesen wäre,
welche Diagnose würden Sie als Arbeitsdiagnose stellen?
Sie müssen eine Tumor denken.
Es kann eine Geilenwegs-Kazinom sein.
Es kann aber auch etwas anderes sein.
Was würden Sie im Ultraschall sehen?
Sie können im Ultraschall sagen.
Ich kann bei Sonographie eine Tumor sehen.
Sie können einen Tumor verursachen.
Sie können einen Galenwege blockieren.
Ich habe Sie aufgehalten.
Sie möchten Ihre Diagnose bestätigen.
Ich würde eine Diagnose bestätigen.
Ich würde eine ERCP bestätigen.
Das ist falsch.
Sie müssen eine Diagnose bestätigen.
Sie müssen eine Tumor bestätigen.
Ich würde eine Diagnose bestätigen.
Ich würde eine Gastroenterologische Anforderung bestätigen.
Vielen Dank.
Sie haben etwas gut gemacht.
Es gibt in diesem Fall viele Möglichkeiten.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Was machen Sie?
Ich muss meine Ergebnisse abwarten.
Ich denke auch.
Aber meine erste Prüfung.
Ich kann nicht beurteilen.
Sie haben eine Diagnose bestätigt.
Ich habe eine Versuchung gemacht.
Man kann z.B. über welche Systeme.
Ich möchte eine Frage.
Sie haben gesagt, wie man eine Pancreas-Tumor erkennen kann.
Sie können nicht immer eine Pancreas-Tumor sehen.
Wenn man eine Pancreas-Karpus oder eine Pancreas-Cauda-Karzinom hat,
dann würde man keine Schollestase machen.
Man kann eine Schollestase sehen.
Man kann eine Pancreas-Karzinom oder eine Tomor machen.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ein Diagnostisch.
Sie müssen nicht vergessen, dass Sie einen CT machen.
Sie können eine RCP nicht sehen.
Sie können eine Endosonografie machen.